la relève de tous ces navigateurs
prestigieux s'est exercé durant ce
week-end de la pentecôte au large du
havre à l'occasion des régates
organisées dans le cadre du 120e
anniversaire du club du sport nautique
de la ville à bord de leur voilier de
type optimiste 86 enfants de moins de 12
ans s'en sont donné à coeur joie
durant trois jours au cours d'épreuves
plutôt difficiles sophie cattoire
à la question maman les p'tits bateaux
qui vont sur l'eau font-ils des jambes
ses enfants ce sont très certainement
entendu répondre non alors surprise
stupéfaction ils ont bien sûr voulu en
savoir davantage et c'est pourquoi un
beau jour ils ont choisi de prendre eux
mêmes le large
aujourd'hui alors qu'ils ont à peine un
peu plus que l'âge de raison
les techniques de navigation ou ont pu
re plus de quinze secret à bord de leur
optimiste ils peuvent affronter vents et
marées tout aussi tranquillement que de
vieux loup de mer ou presque car quand
on creuse un peu le sujet certains de
ces navigateurs en culottes courtes sont
tout de même d'accord pour reconnaître
leurs faiblesses c'est combien tu passé
comme est une mesure sais pas combien je
me dis en espèces dans les vingt-sept et
c'est pas difficile quand on passe 27
kilos de faire de la voile comme ça tout
seul pendant presque cinq heures six
heures d'affilée
quand il ya du vent c'est dur quand il
parle on ne sait pas dire ça assez forte
pour ce genre de sport way quelques fois
tu te dis pas où là j'ai du mal là c'est
dur quand même
oui quelques fois je me dis fais de la
voile de kiko 20 en deux ans et c'est
difficile pour toi ça dépend des jours
aujourd'hui ça a été un petit peu long
non oui on commet là tout de suite un
peu fatigué
raconte moi commence à se dérouler
l'épreuve d'aujourd'hui pour toi lui
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait des vagues
et puis là jean fournet comme aux jeux
olympiques ce week-end au havre
l'important ce n'était pas de gagner
mais bien sûr de participer comme en
témoigne julie coria n'aurait pu
assombrir à côté moi comment ça s'est
passé sur l'eau ouais ça s'est bien
passé
la première manche a été mieux que les
autres quand elle était moins bien parce
que j'ai dit abandonner y avait passé
devant et la deuxième la deuxième ça et
bien les sauf que j'étais important
ils ont fermé la ligne devant moi et la
troisième la troisième jeu ces dernières
et après à part ça je trouve que sa
démarche est oui pour d'autres
participants la course s'est tout de
même déroulée de façon plus
encourageantes comme pour les nollet ce
qui est sorti vainqueur de cette
troisième manche
un bon départ mais après j'ai contrôlé
le reste ça a été facile quoi est ce que
tu fais beaucoup de courses
oui bah tout ça le alix et rien à neuf
dans l'année plus tu as tout cinq
régates nationales et deux ou trois
autres ligues
c'est important pour tout le score est
assez pour sa forme quoi et la forme il
fallait effectivement la voir tout au
long de ce week-end de la pentecôte où
ses 86 enfants se sont affrontés sur
cinq régates à raison de trois dimanche
et deux lundi
c'est jean marie le modu si un micro qui
remporte cette fougue du président mais
il convient de rendre hommage à
l'ensemble des participants car ils ont
tous fait preuve d'un très bon esprit et
d'une endurance remarquable bravo à tous